hey everybody dog walkers here first of
all I'm not dying this is just something
I want to do for the 10 year uh second
I'm going to put this video at the end
of the norm of the north review but I
didn't want that to get away the charity
shout out by the way thanks to everyone
that donates to those you know they
apparently get a lot clicked a lot of
donations and very very kind of you and
you know it go share more there's so
many great charities out there that
definitely could use your support so you
know definitely I keep giving to that uh
but yeah I want to do just a little
video on its own talking about the fact
I've been doing this - a critic for ten
years ten years it's just so crazy and I
felt there definitely should be a video
about it just something really quick and
the you know I started out doing it as a
hobby it was just something I thought
will be kinda entertaining cuz I love
movies of going through a nostalgic
phase and I love certain comedic
characters like Daffy Duck and Lewis
Black just sort of all these likeable
jerks I want to sort of combine that all
together just for fun I didn't think I'd
be doing this ten years later you always
kind of hope maybe it'll catch on but
you know reality saying it's probably
not but you want to try it anyway you
want to do it because you can look back
and say even if it didn't go anywhere
you're glad you did it uh so here we are
ten years later and so many of you were
there from the beginning showing your
support and it's gone through all sorts
of various places eyes and lows peaks
and valleys and I feel like you guys
have always kind of been there uh it's
there's always that cliche where people
are like you know we're we couldn't do
it without you we couldn't do without
you um but that really is true and they
maybe some say it just you know yeah
well you know even then even people
using it as like a strategy to keep you
watching that's acknowledging they still
need you but like so many people have
said before like yeah I love watching
your stuff because it really helped me
through things I just need that bit of
comedy Andy talking about this stuff not
familiar with or I like hearing about
and they really helped me get
give me through all these things and I
if that wasn't the original intention I
was just doing this because it was kind
of fun and I guess there is something to
needing that little element of fun
needing that is gave which is needing a
good time you know with a little thought
behind it too not much to me it is still
my stuff but but you know that me and
going to conventions and meeting fans
and stuff like that so many people come
up and say you've had such a big impact
I really want to emphasize something
that's very very important
you always people we say oh you've had a
big impact on me you guys have literally
changed my life and that is no joke at
all I know there's other elements I know
there's like a lot of hard work a lot of
support from people you work with but
really all of this could not happen if
you guys weren't constantly coming back
and showing your support and just
wanting to have a good time so it really
works both ways and there really are not
words to convey how thankful I am
you guys coming back and constantly
watching what we do has allowed me to
you know to live in a house to you know
move out of my parents place you know
this all started to living with my focus
started off as a freelance illustrator
this was a hobby but it allowed me to
work with a company I loved work with a
boss that I love work with great people
great actors prop makers a family it
allows me to work with family it creates
this world this environment this
connection that really is so wonderful
and I know how lucky I am I know this is
very rare that this happens that you get
job you love those much and you have
this much creative freedom there really
aren't that many fields of entertainment
where you get as much freedom as I do
and I think a lot of that comes from you
guys saying yes we want to see that we
want to see what this guy has to say
even we don't always agree with it or
like it like we want to hear it and we
want to share it and we want
- we want to experience it and just all
of that really all of that does come
from you constantly coming back for 10
years saying we're not tired of this yet
we still want to hear what you had to
say in the various ways they had to say
it and the other actors coming in and
other writers and other content creators
and other producers and Channel awesome
and just all of this you guys keep
coming back to that and it really
changed my life
I mean I know I already said that but I
mean really think about that it changed
my life you guys have really changed my
life and it's it's hard to find the
words even for a Rambler like me uh for
just how thankful I am for that and I
can't believe it's been 10 years and I
don't think I can never really repay
that enough I can't repay how much you
guys have changed my life but I will try
I will try to make as many videos as I
can as much content as I can and keep
keep sharing and keep making stuff that
hopefully you enjoy and trying different
things and trying some of the stuff that
you guys enjoy and keep coming back to
that so yeah there um like I said it's
just ten years it's just saying that
those words out loud is so strange and
I'm just gonna go on rambling if I keep
saying that over and over so really what
comes down to is just me saying thank
you so much for all the dedication all
the love all the support even just doing
it once in a while going haha that's
funny right I hate that guy whatever
it's still support it's still coming in
and and saying I want to hear what this
guy has to say uh it's it's like
visiting a friend it's just coming along
say I wonder what what's going on this
guy's life and you leave comments and
you talk about you have discussions and
stuff and you know some are friendly
some are not so friendly some are very
intelligent some are a couple letters
specific it could be anything uh I love
it all I just love the fact that any of
this is possible and I love that I live
at a time where any of this is possible
you don't have to go and do the
Hollywood route I'm you can actually
kind of bring this stuff to you
you can bring this community to you and
you can grow this community and so many
people come together you know to make
this happen you know with like my boss
make my shot and my brother Rob and
Malcolm a Tamara and Jim and my dad I
did all these people and all the other
content creators on Channel awesome just
working so hard to constantly entertain
you and it's just it's it's so amazing
it's just so phenomenal that for 10
years you have come back just to chill
just to laugh just to whatever share
something that's enjoyable to you and I
enjoy sharing it with you so just thank
you so much
not only for changing my life but for
just sharing something very enjoyable so
that's it I think it's about that I
rambled on long enough but really there
there are not words to express how
thankful I am so just a simple thank you
is what I'm trying to get across thank
you so much for 10 wonderful years
hopefully we can give you a ten more
you